merci beaucoup merci beaucoup et bonjour
à ceux qui nous rejoignent seulement
maintenant oui aujourd'hui dans la voie
libre nous recevons marie-guite dufay la
présidente socialiste de la nouvelle
région bourgogne franche comté
lilian on commence donc cette deuxième
partie avec notamment des questions de
téléspectateurs des questions sur le
programme sur votre action c'est surtout
là dessus que porte les questions en
commençant par une question michel qui
recouvre un point que vous avez évoquées
dans votre discours alors je crois que
vous l'avez évoqué d'ailleurs en parlant
de l'identité de la nouvelle région
bourgogne franche comté en parlant de la
mise en place de tergv entre dijon et
besançon
alors d'abord dit non c'est un ter gv et
pour vous qui vous nous direz peut-être
après si l'union des deux villes elle
est très importante mais d'abord le
tergv c'est quoi mais le principe dans
mon esprit du thv c'est que tous les
usagers de cette ligne besançon dijon
qui sont très nombreux il ya coup
bisontins qui tous les jours prennent le
train pour aller travailler à dijon et
vice versa et bien que les usagers du
ter ceux qui ont un abonnement ter
puisse aussi emprunter les tgv avec le
même tarif
ce qui permet d'avoir plus d'offres dont
d'avoir une offre plus souple et donc
cela faciliterait les laissez-passer
transistors supplément
donc cela est l'objet d'une négociation
avec la linafoot but avec la sncf
devient elle est suffisamment ardue pour
qu'effectivement j'ai sollicité
guillaume pepy lui même ce mois ci est
question dijon besançon parce que l'idée
c'est quand même que les deux capitales
des deux anciennes régions soient reliés
encore plus c'est un tc l'aps le plus
fréquenté un de toutes façons de tous
les ter
et puis effectivement ces deux villes
qui se font tourner le dos jusqu'à
maintenant ont intérêt à travailler
ensemble à grandir ensemble sur un an
votre campagne voilà en plus vous laisse
je suppose envoyer un signal aussi sont
des villes qui ont manifestement de très
grande complémentarité et il faut qu'on
arrive à construire la une une zone
dynamique entre dijon et besançon au
tablant sur les points forts de ces deux
belles villes alors justement vos
vice-président du disais tout à l'heure
ils sont quinze français d'ailleurs les
premiers visages et de ses ter gv et
comment vont-ils travailler et on se
dérouler les sessions du conseil
régional les sessions du conseil
régional vont se dérouler
essentiellement à dijon pour ce qui
concerne les assemblées plénières
parce que pour qu'elle se déroule à
besançon il faudrait des travaux donc
pour l'instant la salle n'est pas les
grands rappelle que l'objectif de la
fusion c'est de faire des économies
alors donnez pas dépenser plus là donc
c'est pour ça que je vous dis que les
assemblées plénières ont naturellement
se dérouleront à dijon que par contre la
salle des assemblées à besançon
permettra d'accueillir ce que nous
appelons les commissions permanentes
c'est à dire les assemblées qui se
réunissent pour exécuter un pour
délibérer sur les exécutions des
décisions que nous avons prises en
assemblée plénière
ces commissions permanentes sont plus
réduites la loi réduit la commission
permanente de notre région à 33 membres
donc je souhaite qu'elle soit a besoin
est ouverte
espagne et est ouverte au public ça
c'est pas tranché le principe d'une
commission permanente c'est quand même
moins d'être ouvert au public qu'une
assemblée plénière c'est ce sont des
c'est vraiment un travail d'exécution
par contre je pense que un point presse
préalable à besançon effectivement peut
être intéressant les vice présidentes
j'en parlais au début de ma question
ils vont habiter où habitait enfin
habiter pour travailler ou revoir numéro
ou vous rendre à leur bureau au nous
sommes en train d'organiser les bureaux
il y a des bureaux principaux à besançon
des bureaux principaux à dijon selon les
délégations qu'ils ont et aujourd'hui
la répartition géographique des
directions administratives de la région
n'est pas fait mais donc effectivement
c'est en fonction de cette répartition
que des vice présidents seront amenés à
avoir plus tôt leur bureau principal à
besançon ou plutôt leur bureau principal
à disons et ce que je souhaitais faire
aussi c'est que chaque vice-président et
sous son autorité
un conseiller délégué pour couvrir
l'autre partie de l'ancienne région
alors un mot quand même sur le siège
c'est une question c'est que si vous
voulez le siège vous voulez que je ne
sois pas besançon il faudra une majorité
particulière pour ça quel est votre
projet ce que vous souhaitez que le
siège de la nouvelle région bourgogne
franche comté administrativement soit à
besançon ou parce que vous souhaitez
transférer à dijon
compte tenu du fait que les séances
plénières se déroule on l'a écouté à
tout cela va faire partie de débat rhin
et nous avons six mois pour trancher
donc pas de réponse non plus 26 je
voulais continuer avec une question
peut-être une question qui était dans la
campagne en question signé mermet
maréchal qui nous pousse questions sur
l'aéroport de dole tavaux alors vous je
vous vois me regarde et me disant ça y
est la campagne recommence on sait que
françois sauvadet voulait soutenir
prendre que la région prenne la gestion
mais la part de nos travaux et y compris
le financement des lignes low cost qui
décollent de la base vous vous êtes
prononcé différemment est ce que ça
signifie que parce que le conseil
départemental du jura si je ne m'abuse a
dit que si la gauche gagne et il a
arrêté de payer l'aéroport de dole
tavaux donc il va se passer quoi est ce
que demain la compagnie low cost qui
volent là bas va arrêter de voler à dole
et ce qu'on ferme aéroport de dole
qu'est ce que vous faites je pense que
tout ça est à la fois beaucoup plus
compliqué il est peut-être qu'on aime
tant que j'en ai pourtant déjà 12 et en
même temps peut-être beaucoup plus
simple le département du jura il a une
délégation de service public pour que
cet aéroport soit gérée comme l'a voulu
le département jusqu'en 2019
donc nous avons le temps me semble-t-il
de voir comment construire à la fois une
nouvelle gouvernance de cet aéroport
et puis provoqué un nouveau modèle
économique
j'ai toujours dis qu'effectivement les
lignes low cost qui ne font qu emmener
des passagers bourguignon et dijonnais
vers des destinations du sud c'était
très bien pour ceux qui utilisent ces
destinations mais que ça ne ramenez rien
sur le territoire en terme de pouvoir
d'achat de développement du tourisme et
il fallait arriver à trouver des lignes
qui équilibre donc s'il ya des lignes
qui vont vers le sud pourrait peut-être
qu'il y ait aussi des lignes tu viennes
du nord et paix qui nous amène du nord
les scandinaves les écossais les onglets
qui vient s'arrêter si nous amène à
londres dole et google et que nous et
qui viennent découvrir les hospices de
beaune comme mission la gestion pourrait
se faire le modèle économique est à
trouver et qu'après la gestion je vous
dis on en a jusqu'à 2019 un de toute
façon donc on on a le temps mais là au
revoir et nous dire que la porte n'est
pas totalement faux je n'ai jamais fermé
la porte
j'ai été constante sur cette question
trouvons un autre modèle économique
regardons quels sont les besoins pour un
territoire comme le nôtre en terme
d'aéroports une question d'un
téléspectateur qui vous demandent
comment allez vous rendre compte de
votre activité auprès des citoyens
alors ça c'est une belle et énorme
question même pas simplement l'allier
n'est pas simplement le fait de rendre
compte
c'est la question de la citoyenneté je
vous disais que ce dont avait souffert
le plus pendant la campagne c'était de
l'indifférence des citoyens et donc des
électeurs
mais ce gouffre qu'il ya entre les gens
les habitants et citoyens et les aigus
mais c'est devenu tellement énorme que
ce n'est plus supportable alors c'est
plus compliqué pour une région par
rapport à une ville d'amener les
citoyens dans ses politiques publiques
néanmoins il faut le faire et un de mes
premiers chantiers
c'est bien de d'inventer des voies
nouvelles comment on amène les citoyens
à participer à l'élaboration de nos
politiques publiques
comment on rencontre régulièrement je
demanderai j'organiserai des comptes
rendus de mandat régulier par mes vice
présidents
je ne sais pas encore sous quelle forme
et vous savez pendant la campagne j'ai
essayé de provoquer le débat avec les
cafés débats pour été un petit peu
vilipendé par certains qui en fait on a
lu je n'avais fait presque une centaine
on sait tous combien j'en ai fait moi
j'en demande en a fait pas mal est
vraiment le constat il est très positif
parce que c'est notre façon à nous
adresser aux gens vous aurez le temps
d'animer vous même des cafés-débats
peut-être pas moi j'ai quinze
vice-présidents autant de conseillers
délégués et je pense que ils auront
chacun mission probablement parents
d'animer au moins trois cafés débats
vous allez voir c'est une question qui
rejoint votre préoccupation donc
stéphane qui nous demandent quelles
actions allez vous mener vis-à-vis des
territoires abandonnés
il sait y cite par exemple le grès loi
et le tonnerrois mais est ce que la
région aura une plus grande donc c'est
difficile de jouer la proximité
à ce moment là sauf que il est évident
que l'organisation de la nouvelle région
doit être profondément différente de ce
qu'elle était jusqu'à maintenant elle ne
doit plus être centralisée comme elle
l'était les décisions c'est moi qui les
prend les décisions seront prises dijon
et besançon bien entendu mais il faut
trouver une autre organisation
territoriale pour que nous soyons
réactif par rapport au territoire
réactif par rapport à toutes les
initiatives qui existent et qui porte le
développement des territoires que nous
les entendions que nous impulsion que
nous les poussions que ce ça passera ou
culturelles oui et que ce soit aussi
bien au niveau économique sociaux
économiques culturels
il y a dans les territoires des
initiatives de toutes sortes pense
spontanément aux premières initiatives
qui aujourd'hui ramène de l'emploi et de
l'activité qui sont les initiatives
liées aux nouvelles énergies
li à ce qu'on appelle les territoires à
énergie positive mais c'est fou toutes
les initiatives qu'il n'y a pas de la
part de particuliers comme de la part
d'associations c'est pas pour rien que
j'ai parlé des potes les pionniers
ordinaire de la transition énergétique
c'est ce tu déjà invente des nouveaux
circuits de chaleur des nouvelles façons
de se déplacer est tous là bas il faut
effectivement que ce soit poussé par la
collectivité et donc il faut que nous
nous dotions d'une organisation plus
déconcentrés et ça c'est vraiment un
premier devoir un premier premier
travail
oui dans les trois axes que j'évoquais
tout à l'heure vous avez parlé la
croissance verte
vous avez dit dans vos discours je crois
au formidable potentiel de la croissance
verte
on veut bien vous croire et pour autant
notre région tire une partie de sa
richesse de l'industrie automobile de
l'industrie du nucléaire voire de la
plasturgie est ce que fait compatibles
et 2 il faut les deux il faut les deux
il faut que ce qui a fait la force de
notre industrie et bien prennent le
chemin de la diversification pour
continuer à être dans la bataille
industrielle et quand je vois les
clusters qui se met en place que ce soit
le cluster automobile que ce soit au
niveau de notre haute précision cluster
santé et clusters arizona et roddick ont
sans aucun niveau industriel nous avons
des forces formidable mais la croissance
verte c'est à la fois ce que l'on fait
pour réduire la consommation d'énergie
et ça passe notamment par des
rénovations et des constructions et
derrière c'est l'activité dont le
bâtiment a tant besoin
et puis c'est miser sur les énergies
renouvelables
sur l'éolien sur le solaire sur le bois
énergie sur l'hydroélectricité
nous avons lancé un programme de
territoire à énergie positive notre
région peut à terme être une région qui
ne consomme pas plus d'énergie qu'elles
n'en qui produit autant d'énergie
qu'elle en consomme
et ça c'est une formidable source de
développement
je prends par exemple la question des
éoliennes c'est pas simplement produire
de l'énergie plus vertueuse 6 se doter à
partir de nos compétences industrielles
notamment en chaudronnerie
notamment en électromécanique des
capacités de construire les mâts
d'éoliennes qui aujourd'hui viennent
d'autriche sinon de chine
dernière question marie-guite dufay
parce qu'il reste moins d'une minute à
quoi à quel signe vous pourrez vous dire
j'ai réussi la fusion bourgogne franche
comté
je vous demande pas un âge où le mandat
qu'elle signe quand j'entendrai secondes
quand j'entre andré -2 -2 plane sur le
fait qu' on risque d'être mangés par
la bourgogne voilà je ne veux plus
entendre cela et si je ne l'entend plus
qu'honorable hisse au cours de haut pour
votre mandat on aura donc l'occasion
d'en reparler
on aura l'occasion de peut-être de vous
faire le bilan avec vous dans un an
en attendant bien sûr tout au long de
cette année 2016 nous parlerons de cette
fusion bourgogne franche comté puisque
ce sera craint le grand sujet de
l'actualité politique
merci beaucoup madame merci didier merci
pour votre attention et bon samedi à
tous au revoir